à caligny à quelques pas d'un des géants
de l'équipement automobile
un artisan est en train de mettre en
forme un petit goût des années 20 simone
robinson ferronnier d'art travaille
depuis 10 mois sur cette carrosserie la
partie la plus difficile c'était
l'arrière de la voiture parce que le
châssis se développe en double arrondi
c'est difficile de maintenir cette forme
car le métal rouge parfois de façon
inattendue dans la famille robinson
on travaille le métal depuis le xviie
siècle aux côtés de son père en
angleterre simone s'est spécialisée dans
la forge de l'inox un métal inoxydable
mais très exigeant je fais ça depuis que
j'ai 5 ans dans l'atelier de mon père
j'ai grandi avec
on a travaillé ensemble pendant de
nombreuses années
et moi je continue une association
fructueuse qui a donné naissance à de
magnifiques oeuvres d'art comme ce
portail de six mètres de haut fabriqués
spécialement pour le mariage de charles
et diana
aujourd'hui simone sculpte des pièces
pour les espaces publics les églises et
bien sûr pour des particuliers
ils ont du goût le sens de l'esthétique
alors il commande des oeuvres plus
généralement pour leur maison ou leur
jardin des oeuvres uniques créés
spécialement pour eux et de temps en
temps
simone travail pour lui ou pour le
confort de sa petite famille
comme cette cheminée une pièce unique en
son genre